I don't want to.
If I don't want to believe Shit,
if it,
if it doesn't hurt me,
I it shouldn't be such a big deal.
I want to know right now on this podcast,
who is running this country?
There's a bunch of different factions that you call the government.
History,
science,
education,
energy.
Everything has always been controlled by the government.
Since day one.
Look at the time,
illegal aliens in the workspace as recommended by the commission,
headed by former congresswoman Barbara Jordan.
If you look into the experiments to prove that the earth is spinning,
all of them failed.
Look into it.
You're just having a burned this.
If you look into it and you,
and you have proof that it is round,
instead of going,
oh,
some scientists figured out,
somebody figured it out,
somebody figured out.
But you figure it out.
You try to figure it out.
No,
because when they look into it,
it's common sense.
And when you look into it,
wait a gentleman,
black helicopters have been spotted.
Two 21 holy Shit.
Show
two 2120 for Burt for one pound,
one pound less.
One fucking pound.
You fucking do 16 Tom gets it running away.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I want to do the Puerto Rican beard.
I'm going to fucking say this.
Puerto Rican guy.
Beard.
Yeah.
It said Puerto Rican facial hair.
Taj Things.
Maybe they knew Burke rd.
Uncomfortable with this.
He's giving you a Hitler Son.
Oh my God.
This is so stupid.
What's wrong with us?
We're all adults.
What's the fuck is wrong with us?
Oh my God.
Can I please see?
So you're doing the prince?
No.
What are you doing today?
Someone's hair in my mouth.
You look really good.
Accurate.
Really?
Yeah.
You're gonna like it.
That's actually not bad and I'm not bullshitting.
You look good.
This feels,
here's the thing,
man.
Oh boy.
I look like I work at blue.
The apes.
I look at him.
Fuck a monkey.
No,
no.
This is not looking you how you definitely don't live in your hometown
and you got to Pennzoil Tattoo.
We can start another contest.
I'm totally comfortable with that.
It seems like Burt wants starting on the content.
I want to start another contest.
I want already to be involved too.
Cause I like Ari's Walton.
What does that mean?
Well there was snakes,
man,
you're 100% but you get,
you lose your beard.
Listen,
you had somebody.
Oh yeah,
true.
Welsh on your bed.
Oh you're so rounds.
I just asked her a measurement of the heights and when they got the national it
was corny line
ours.
Right to ask for this.
How many tweets did you get caught?
You're welcome.
Wow.
Boston.
It'll keep you all want to say like five hours.
You would have to really prepare that time.
He's willing.
I want to see where he's at number.
What shape right now.
So wait,
he,
you didn't get to really prepare to do five hours.
I think you could do it.
I'm not saying you couldn't do it.
If we're not giving you a year,
idiot,
fuck you're going to do it.
What's the next marathon?
What's the what?
What city are they going to be in San Diego,
la.
Fuck.
Cause like say next weekend if I had a girlfriend,
she might say it's Friday.
What are we doing?
I'm like,
oh,
watching me write for four hours.
And so that's not the way to be.
You can't do that.
So I can't be a good persons other half because I'm always,
the work has always attracted me more than coming home to someone.
Wow.
Like I,
I can't stand the idea of someone of living with a person.
I can do it on the bus,
cause this das boat and work,
you know,
going down the road.
Um,
but I,
I never would want to like wake up and she's there.
I have no,
no aversion.
We'll get expression,
but he's like,
look to your right.
She's there as well.
It's every day here we are together and I'm just not wired that way.
So,
um,
so he's the main figurehead,
right?
Right.
He's the main guy like right up with Miscavige.
And then John Travolta somewhere in that,
I think
John was given what,
uh,
um,
a designation called con where they hunt.
Could con not,
can't good con.
Yeah.
Okay.
Kakao.
Okay.
He's given this designation of cocoon,
which there's a policy that basically says you can kill another human being.
If you were conned,
you're going to look the other way.
And he was given,
he was given that by l Ron Hubbard.
Don't make me laugh cause you gonna make me think.
Imagine thousands of emails come out with them talking about,
we'll have the kids ready,
six,
seven and eight in the hot tub at this time.
And there'd be,
I don't see anything like that.
Oh,
it gets you,
it gets really clear.
Where did it say that it was in those emails?
There's fricking thousands of them,
but it said,
we'll get the kids in the hot tub.
Yes.
I never saw that.
Can you,
can you see if you could find that Jamie?
That seems like,
Ooh,
I got so confusing now.
The libs,
you confuse every and nobody knows what bathroom to use.
And I was at a night club the other night and here's the ladies room right here.
And the men's room was right next to is a pile of shit in the middle
with a tampon stuck in,
in a fake mustache
and it won't last long.
Hold on.
Immediate head rush,
by the way.
Really?
Oh by the way,
don't inhale it.
Just puff it.
Well,
I'm a pot smoker,
bro.
Well you don't want to hail that.
There's no filter on that.
What are your buzzy,
but often it's mind blowing when you learn that some infinities are bigger than
others.
Joe Rogan just lean two feet away from the microphone and the properties of each
of those regions,
whether they're conducive to forming galaxies and stars and planets and people
may be different.
So we could say logically in that picture that the reason the universe looks
like the way it does is because we're here to measure it.
Oh my God,
we should leave it at that.
Okay.
We should close with that.
That is the mind blower blowers and you know,
iron man has that blue thing in his chest.
Yeah.
I don't think women are evil.
I like iron woman or iron man.
Their magic.
Right.
But by ripping out that blue thing,
you're ripping out their ability to have children and be mothers and everything,
and then you put in a piece of shit into iron man's chest.
That's what feminists and like this woman are there.
Shit chests.
They're malfunctioning.
Robots kill Em.
Milo wants genocide killing.
So do you think that they're imitating what they think are patriarchal
societies?
They're doing their version of it and that's what they're doing with this.
The whole matriarchal posturing.
It's like Clark Kent,
I want to run an article.
I'm writing.
No,
you're not running it and you'd go Clark,
simmer down.
Dude.
I look at the things that I went through as a gift because I have gotten a gift
of feeling
retired during my career.
Who else gets that?
Some people retire for five years,
lose their freaking mind and up in the bar and come back and try to fight again.
10 years later was a weakened body.
A mass comm.
Abuse.
Why?
Why though?
Why are they doing that?
They're not doing it because they're physically capable.
They're doing it because they never dealt with their life away from fighting.
Fighting was there like fighting is who they are.
Fighting is their persona.
So take away fighting.
What are they?
They're in the bar drinking away with.
They're not,
instead of drinking,
putting the booze down and knowing what you are without fighting,
being happy with that chapter of your life and being able to live who you are.
I've gotten to feel that and now I can fight with a peace of mind,
knowing how good I am without fighting and how great I am with it too.
And um,
that's,
that's what this thing's about.
All these fights,
all these me attacking those challenges,
coming back and winning and getting my belt back.
Um,
that could only happen because I let go of control of the things I couldn't
control.
Yeah,
he had,
he would be the first man I think about that kind of stuff.
I give a plane crash.
I already know I'm planning ahead.
Did I eat a Vietnamese guy?
Why?
Because that's easy.
It's start or move.
If you attack somebody bigger,
you eat somebody bigger in front of other people.
It's going to alarm people.
But you,
you gotta eat a small person.
So stature is important.
I think if you come down a Viet,
people aren't going to be that upset at Ya.
Well that means people are going to be super upset.
What are you talking about?
Tony's dad?
Yeah,
their sacrifice.
They're more understanding of things,
dude,
this is the character you're playing.
No,
but if you eat a black dude,
you eat a black lady and her family's here,
they're going to be pissed.
So you think at Vietnamese person,
we'll let you slide.
I think that they'd be much more forgiving over a couple of day period.
I think a like their relatives.
You don't think so?
Honestly one thing.
No,
I don't think so.
I definitely think there'd be super pissed at you,
especially modernized ones.
But what is interesting is like Vietnam is one of the few places where um,
Americans can go back to Vietnam and they don't seem to hold any grudge at all.
Exhibit a
exhibit a man.
Honestly.
Do you realize 87% gout poll came out last year?
It's at 87% of the people on the planet or unhappy with what their life is all
about now on habitat and 10% in addition to that,
87 to 97 hey,
what they do little so that leaves 3% of the planet.
Enjoy what they do.
You're one to 3%.
Fuck,
I'm a one of the 100 millions of a percent.
Uh,
I,
I'm so happy.
I don't know whether to shit or go blind.
Yes.
So
I ended up,
you know,
going to the restroom,
looking at the shit kicked all over.
It was like,
it must have been in between rounds.
Disgusting.
I was like,
there's no trashcan.
It's like silk and gold in this beautiful palace and stuff.
So I just like take my panties off and just like roll them up and shove him
behind the toilet.
Black
Lace Thong Vladimir Putin.
That was mine.
I want to,
I want it back.
No,
I don't want it back.
Oh,
it was,
you know,
in 2000 it was 10 years ago and it's crap.
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
and then I just go back out there and it's like Berlusconi was like hitting on
me and like trying to pick me up and he's like,
Hey,
can I be your boyfriend tonight?
And I'm just like,
what?
But he's saying it through a translator so it was so and I'm like,
I smell like shit like that cause I couldn't do it was up to our dirty
motherfucker.
That was a war on drugs.
We started one drugs.
Turns out we're bringing it in.
Then there's a war on terrorism.
Turns out we created al Qaeda.
You understand why I'm crazy.
I'm crazy because of that shit.
I'm like,
if that's real to you man,
she don't think it's real with fish.
I fish.
I had done,
you guys are fooled by the Fisheye Lens.
C'Mon man.
Is that what the fuck is going on with?
I don't know.
I don't want you think there's a conspiracy in the conspiracy and then they'll
cut the gym home long or Jim Kim Jong.
Oo Cold.
I'm not saying they're actors,
I'm just saying there's something fishy about the whole North Korea thing.
Turn around a source.
Rex is a giant kangaroo.
That's what it is.
That's my guess.
That's a fucking,
they found a giant kangaroo and when they figured it out to go do it,
it's a kangaroo or they were like,
let's skip off what told you I'm crazy,
but what's the advantage that's not round you?
You got to appreciate the hustle by Eddie Jones is like absolute belts,
conspiracy theorists.
You'd have the,
wow,
I can't believe you said that.
The,
exactly.
There's giant weather modification systems and there's weather wars between
different governments.
I want to know how he got,
I want to know the story of how he got in.
Is there a,
is there a video out there?
Scientology,
Scientology who,
how did he get in?
We are allowing this to happen.
It's like we want it to happen.
It's like it's a CIA,
Mk ultra experiment.
What do you mean?
I always wondered how they're getting away with it.
It's so out in the open.
How come there isn't more psychic vampires stealing the energy from the kids
were taking these people on.
We're bringing God back in.
He would swear that wasn't very religious,
like Trump has gotten religion learning about this because let me tell you
something.
Trump's not a devil worshiper and he loves God and he's been briefed on all this
and he's gonna roll their ass up so the pedophiles better get ready to do the
rob trials even exists.
That could be a conspirator.
Can I,
can I say one thing?
The Rothschilds are a hoax.
I just know all this crap.
You get crazy.
People won't listen to me because I got too much data and you imagine what this
is like.
You think that they drop,
they would have dropped the ball big time like earnest Byner in 1987 for the
browns.
He would have dropped the ball.
If you're not,
if you don't have paid shills online,
strategically pushing the agenda is only controlled of Ai.
How'd they get?
How'd the pedophiles getting controlled?
Okay.
Do you know that if you go to youtube and you punch in Nikola Tesla hoax fraud,
nothing comes up.
Put in Albert Einstein hoax fraud,
endless videos.
It's,
Oh,
it was a free
videos and there was a full out war inside the government of guys that liked
each steaks,
drink beer and have women versus a bunch of Potbelly pedophiles.
Whoa.
I don't know what to believe,
man.
I don't know if the Rothschilds are real.
I don't know of Reptilians of Rio.
I Dunno.
Satanism Israel.
I don't know.
Shit.
We using human technology to try to take our best minds and build some type of
breakaway civilization where they're going to merge with machines,
transcend and break away from the failed species that has man will power.
That's not,
no.
Okay.
Let's,
uh,
that's about it folks.
Time take one day.
If I give you full power,
you're going to be in the hall,
but no one has the time to do Everest,
to micro manage the entire world to this.
Right.
It's just,
there's,
there's only so much shit you can let people take care of them live.
I guess you could let people take care of themselves.
Illuminati got Ki
Ki
got enough time for mind control experiments.
There's too much shit going on.
I gotta ask you this one thing for sure is because I read this and I was like,
what?
Um,
here we go.
Uh,
you saw someone shape shift.
Oh God.
Is it,
is that really where you fucking with people?
That's true.
Really.
Yeah.
It's true.
Because when you told me that joy Kaufman like moments,
I was like,
okay,
I know it's true.
I would tell you off grade,
but I won't say it publicly.
Right.
But I mean,
has anybody had been skeptical?
Does anybody yeah.
Everyone's skeptical.
Yeah.
What's your response to that?
You don't know what I know,
right?
Well,
do you know though?
I can't,
I don't know.
I can't tell you some of the shit that I know,
but that jury is still out.
So what are the negative benefits or the negative affects of this?
This is an explosive,
uh,
area of conversation and it puts my life in danger.
So I reserve the right not to answer a question.
Whoa.
I didn't expect that.
It puts your life in danger talking about Portabella mushrooms.
He's looking at me silently.
I will respectfully move on.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I mean business,
there's never encounter each find suits,
no pocket squares.
Occasionally you find a t token pocket square,
but you can tell their heart's not in it.
The wife stuck in there cause she's so someone on TV that hadn't been at rent
razzle dazzle about them and they thought,
oh I quite fancy my old man man,
one of them and they would stick it in the old man's be embarrassed about it and
trust us.
Squeeze out of the way.
Suits are a thing.
The death of the suit,
it was the death of the suit was the present attitude toward Ongo Noah and I'll
go,
oh yeah,
I won't put a tie on and on.
I don't want us to count.
That's how I feel.
But that's what's happened.
We've been brainwashed to not dress
line gentlemen.
But I see a guy like you and I say that's appealing.
I look how you're dressed and you're in a conservative suit.
This is a nicer,
like I'm sure you could wear any suit you wanted but you chose assert that has a
certain look to it.
Yeah.
I have spent some time asking around with this Joe,
but a bit like the same reason that we spent our time asking around with our
pocket square.
It's,
I remember thinking how much I found the suit repugnant and I became angry that
the suit had been robbed from us,
and so I had to create an alibi,
a way in to understand why is that?
I'd like a suit
and you have many puzzles in front of you that you could solve,
but you choose not to.
You know that.
Those are the things that weigh on your conscience.
It's like,
you know why I should really do this,
but you don't.
It's like so I had this idea a long time ago because the world is a pretty
dreadful place.
I thought,
well,
what would the world be like if people stopped avoiding the things they knew
they should do?
You know?
Guess the question is how much are we contributing to the fact that life is a,
is an existential catastrophe and a tragedy?
How much is our own corruption contributing to that?
How to really worthwhile question the things you leave undone because you're
angry,
you're resentful,
you're lazy,
you have a neuro Shia,
well you consult your conscience and it says,
well,
you know,
got a place over there,
could use a little work.
It's the same as working on yourself.
And so you clean that up because you can,
and then things are a little clearer around you and you're a little better off
because you've practiced a bit and and so you're a little stronger.
And then something else manifest itself and says,
well maybe you could like take a crack at fixing me up too.
So he decided to do that and then that gets a little bit more pristine,
you know,
when soon.
And it's,
it's humble because you're not exceeding your domain of competence.
You know,
it's like,
don't be fixing up the economy.
18 year old,
you don't know anything about the economy.
It's a massive complex machine beyond anyone's understanding.
And you mess with it at your peril.
So when can you even clean up your own room?
No.
Well you should think about that.
You should think about that because if you can't even clean up your own room,
who the hell are you to give advice to the world?
And in the morning,
this hooker,
um,
she just tells me like,
how much,
how much I owe her.
Right.
And I'm like,
that's fucking outrageous.
There's no fucking way I was,
I'd say it was like,
basically,
I don't care if you're a fucking pimp wants to kick my ass and fucking kill me.
I'm not paying that fucking much much for,
I forget it was so long ago.
But,
um,
but yeah,
I was outraged beforehand.
It just,
it just wasn't in that case.
I exactly,
I remember clearly,
I was like,
what do you want that much?
And I said,
I said,
I'll give you this much.
And that's how much he get what period?
And we,
we,
we came out,
right?
Like,
um,
you know,
I got to go film and uh,
well I can through,
uh,
the,
the lobby Knoxville is down there having breakfast.
This hooker comes walking by and knocks on.
She says,
that's not steevo.
That's cheapo.
That would be the scientific approach.
I don't know what it is.
Great mystery.
Let's just wait and see versus a,
I'm going to postulate a lost civilization.
Nothing wrong with that Graham.
It's a free country.
Uh,
and scientists do this all the time as,
as you've mentioned,
there's a rather humorous thing,
which I have to say actually,
I'm not even ask Jamie to pull up the,
um,
the a couple of images.
I mean this is embarrassing.
I remember telling my parents that I wanted to change my name to
Damien Monroe,
crystal Leah to Damien,
Damien Monroe because Damien was is the devil,
right?
Okay.
And then Marilyn Monroe was like pure in my head.
So I was like,
you have both.
I would ask my parents,
I would,
I would ask my peers,
because I always sat like this at the dinner table and I asked him,
I was like,
can you call me crazy legs?
And I remember thinking like,
oh,
like that would be cool.
Like if my family called me crazy legs,
it's Damien crazy legs coming at Ya.
And then they were like,
and my dad was like,
no.
And I was like,
but just like maybe just at least at the dinner table,
I remember saying that and you'd be like,
I'm not fucking calling you crazy leg.
We need you,
Chris,
you were talking about tiger woods and your podcast.
I was listening to on the way over here and I totally agree with you.
Are you saying like when tigers world fell apart?
Like how the fuck do you know?
Like what do you,
did you talk to him like you don't know him?
You know,
that was,
I mean,
that's just a bunch of hype.
Like for him,
it's like a double dump though,
you know?
I mean,
the thing happens personally with his personal life and it happens publicly
where everybody gets to see it.
And then on top of that,
his body's falling apart at the same time no matter what he did.
Yeah.
No matter what.
You're going to church every fucking week.
He was going to fuck up his back and his knees and they,
and it did,
but then they're trying to equate it to,
uh,
you know,
whatever.
The,
I'd say what he did was none of my business,
it's none of my fucking business.
I don't want to know about it.
I hate no one about,
you know,
I feel bad if somebody like,
if the marriage falls apart,
I feel bad if they get busted for drugs,
you know,
I mean,
it happens if you fucked up and it's your fault,
you should get punched.
But like the cops are handling it.
They arrested him.
The courts will handle it.
Do I?
Do I need to talk to,
I need to pile on and start wagging my fucking hypocrite and a finger at them.
It's so immediate that you become this,
you become other,
you become an outsider.
Like in the next morning when he went back,
I rang the doorbell.
I rang the doorbell to your own house and I lived in that house from the day I
was born.
Whoa.
So you felt like you had to ring the doorbell.
If this is not my world anymore.
Wow.
Like,
why don't you ring the doorbell?
And it was like,
there's,
there's no other,
there is,
there is nothing else like it.
This is not our home.
This is not.
So we go and,
you know,
we're packing all of our things.
It was just,
it was awful.
Just,
uh,
I had been in those four months,
I had been so terrified of,
because I know knowing what was coming,
like just imagine you're going to lose everyone in your life.
They're just,
you're just going to like,
you're not going to like how your parents met and fell in love.
Or like your grandparents and family recipes and photos and memories and what
did the House looks?
I'm like taking photos and voice recordings and just all the time,
like an every,
it was just,
it's just,
it's overwhelming.
It's just,
um,
so when you say something like,
well,
you know,
we should be attacking Islam.
Islam as if it's something that is outside of Islam.
That's simply false.
Islam.
Islam is Islam,
right?
Ird,
the one,
the prime minister of Turkey,
and I can quote many other,
uh,
Islamic experts said,
Islam is Islam,
the term moderate Islam,
Islam,
and all these other qualifiers are nonsensical.
And now the reason why that upsets me is because it grants people a false sense
of security and hope,
you know,
Islam is wonderful,
but we need to attack this separate thing called Islamism.
Well,
from day one,
1400 years ago,
Islam was Islamism.
Now,
that doesn't mean that there isn't a spiritual element.
That doesn't mean that most Muslims just want to practice the spiritual part,
but there is no set of doctrines in a separate book called radicalized Islamism.
It all comes from the same texts.
It comes from the Quran,
it comes from the Hedis,
and it comes from the Sera,
the biography of Muhammad.
So,
so this kind of false narrative that people are promulgating so that they seem
as though they're not frontally attacking a religion while laudable.
While Nice,
I get that reflex.
It's false.
I don't know if I talked about my dad with you,
but,
um,
he was my wrestling coach in high school.
Uh,
he was also my,
uh,
earth science,
biology and environmental studies teacher.
She was my teacher.
I want to drag you went to school,
your dad being the tea does fucking,
I learned a lot because he was no joke.
He didn't pull any punches for me.
He,
you know,
he drove me as hard,
if not harder than his other students who didn't show any favoritism.
But one of the things,
it was always his thing on the mat,
and I'm kind of paraphrasing,
but basically you,
you either win or you learn.
Uh,
especially in that high school,
college setting,
you're,
you're learning about yourself.
If you,
if you went out there and you got your ass handed to you and you just got bead
and didn't learn anything,
well yeah,
you're a fucking loser.
Take the moment,
reflect on it,
build on what you did wrong and you now you're actually in a way you've won.
You've now you know more about yourself.
You know about more your,
your limitations are what you need to improve and expand your talents are your
limitations.
So I guess whenever I'm doing a thing,
I'm always looking at it from a learning perspective.
So there aren't necessarily mistakes unless they're fatal and then wouldn't know
anyway.
So whatever.
Cause you see him in a club and he sees,
he sees some girls.
How are you doing?
Like BMW,
when girls go,
what do you like?
You like BMW,
like cars,
like BMWs and crazy.
He'd take the girls out and go get a BMW.
Ah,
there was another guy standing on the wall,
green jacket,
like green little jumpsuit.
Nobody's talking to him.
Guess who was who?
Jay Z.
Nobody
knew.
I said,
what's up man?
He's just a great party.
Cause it wasn't too long after that accident that he had,
right.
And then he goes,
ah,
I,
I got a song dat,
Dat,
you,
you will be gut on.
Uh,
I got the song.
I know you could kill it.
I was like,
me song,
goofy face.
I called Robert.
I said,
listen,
I need you to play a Mexican.
He says,
dude,
here's the deal.
Why not fuck it?
Sure,
of course you're Mexican.
Whatever.
I did an Adam Sandler film.
I don't know that,
that,
uh,
the last one he did the Sandy Wexler and you know,
you go up on the set,
you know,
an Adam starring in this film and I'm not,
you know what I mean?
And I used to star in films and it's,
it's a weird feeling for me.
Like I'm happy to be on the set and I love Adam and he's an old dear friend and
I'm super happy for him,
but I was starring in films,
you know what I mean?
Everywhere I go,
people say,
why aren't you starting in films?
Like,
what?
What's up?
And I can't answer it,
you know what I mean?
Poor choices.
The weasel shit,
dry it up.
Um,
you know,
the movies didn't perform as well.
I didn't listen to my agents.
I wasn't like doing drugs.
It wasn't like,
oh,
got all fucked up.
It's just one movie didn't do so good.
Then the next thing that we didn't do so good and then they eventually just
stopped coming and he told us about money,
shit,
uh,
in his backyard and somebody thought it was a Baird.
She would leave.
She will let her dogs out every day and then she would clean up people.
French poodles,
when you shit outside,
it's not going to be a decent shit.
It's going to be like explosive.
So when I got up,
it looks like somebody got shot in the head that we should all
French poodles Chihuahuas and she's looking at the wall like,
what the fuck happened?
All of a sudden she actually walks up close to it and squint and looks down on
it and looks around and runs in the house.
I'm watching all this.
I can't breathe.
Oh my God.
I took a shit in favor in his backyard after a five hour drive from Colton or
some weird town,
did not talk to you after that for awhile I took a shit and then he ran over it
with his car and the whole back yard,
smelly sewage waste.
I'd go with her the next day.
He goes,
it smells back here.
Let's walk in the house.
I don't know what happened and you can see the brown shit.
You smashed it with this tire and a bunch of flies
to talk to me for a month after that in some of these backyard
because I told him the truth.
I felt bad.
I lied to the guy.
I remember I was telling you guys at one time,
my freshman year,
I didn't take a ship for a week and I had,
I used to,
I was addicted to steak,
comes with American.
Jeez and all right.
A French brothers,
listen to me.
How long is that?
I was in,
I played freshman ball and we were playing Paddison east side.
That's just a jungle of the school.
Like you gotta be careful when you're in there.
And uh,
we went there to play the Christmas tournament,
but what kind of ball are we talking about?
Basketball and I hadn't taken a shift from like 10 days or something.
I took acid,
something to fuck my stomach up.
I didn't tell nobody.
And those days I was really scared of doctors and I wouldn't say shit to nobody.
No Way.
Home.
We got on the bus
and while we were waiting there,
my stomach started hurting and I said,
Jesus Christ,
I don't know if I'm going to shoot myself a Fart,
but let me just take a chance,
and I blew this far.
Joe Rogan.
That was so bad,
right?
We want a bus and people started running,
you know the school buses,
people started running to the window,
goes right to swing down the bus windows,
but here's what you got by the,
I fathered again as the teachers would going,
oh my God,
he's changing flavors.
Yeah.
What's the worst thing was the cheerleaders are crying.
That's how bad they were sitting in front of a bus
or the teachers yell.
There's a building.
It's still there on Franklin and Hollywood where Charles Manson used to live and
run his or is out of,
which I didn't know he was doing.
He was a pimp,
yet pimping girls to people that are staying at the Roosevelt color.
Me Badd.
Right.
Let me,
mine is
perfect color.
Me Badd to Bam,
like you know,
it's a hard one to learn but anything that's got an orgasm at the end of it,
you know,
there's a degree of pleasure to be had but it takes,
it takes a while to recognize or what they see the emotional cost of me to
spiritual cost on other people.
The fact that it's preventing me from becoming a father,
from becoming a husband,
from set Ellyn,
from becoming rooted,
from becoming actually whole,
from becoming a man,
from becoming connected.
And it takes a while to spot that.
I think a lot of people don't get the opportunity to break out that pattern.
I would never have spotted it had a not first being a heroin addict and going
hold on a minute,
you're doing that thing again.
Same with fame and celebrity.
Well toxic,
well toxic,
exciting and brilliant and loads of lovely people in there.
And I still like,
you know,
I might make another film,
I don't know what happened but like it's because I'd had the template and
experiences of awe,
this is addiction.
You're expecting this thing to make you feel bad.
Harvey's and Executive Guy,
right.
Guy,
the money guy behind everything and a coke and caviar and suck my dick
is so nasty.
So gross.
Okay.
Now on the other hand,
on the other hand,
I was like,
you know,
Hollywood is such a labyrinth in terms of like getting shit done and getting
deals closed.
And how did this,
does this happen?
It would kind of be nice to be like,
you want a Netflix special?
Just go fucking suck.
And then I can be like,
oh,
that's all I have to do is suck.
And that guys,
yeah,
come over here.
You Nasty.
Fuck.
And then there's your special,
right.
You know what if you type in,
um,
Astra,
uh,
the tr three be astro,
tr three B
and I'll walk over.
They kind of walk over there for a second.
Sure,
sure.
Go ahead.
This is Mike gone to,
yeah.
So we can all talk to each other.
Sure.
No.
So what you want to do is come down here and do your,
your people get to,
uh,
there'll be able to see it.
We'll put it up on the screen.
So what,
what this is,
um,
well I don't really want to tell you what it is.
What I want you to watch it yet.
Is this,
that's not it.
One more page.
I'll find it for you.
Just takes me a second.
There's a bunch of bullshit.
This is the craft by the way.
And did you spell it right?
Astro.
That's why.
Sorry.
Astra.
Oh,
Astra Astra not astro.
Yeah,
you're typing it.
You just got to get,
we've got to get,
make sure it's the right one.
So the hundred mile race that I was doing a month before Moab add about,
I mean 12 miles roughly to the finish line.
My vision started blurring like in the periphery.
Um,
and over the course of the next couple of miles closed in until it was pure
white.
I couldn't see anything pretty much.
I would say like 98% blind.
What?
I could see my feet like right in front of my feet.
But it was just white out.
When people heard about this,
like they're like problem with like click bait journalism.
The headlines look like I was,
it's like sexual misconduct stuff.
And like,
I don't want to be like,
but like,
uh,
let me just stop you right here.
If you say like one more time,
I fucking head's gonna explode dude.
I get comments like that.
It's brutal.
Isabella,
is it as bad as all right.
I just want you to slow it down.
I'm going to use it every now and then.
This coffee break,
you're breaking the like the like meter
and I,
I'm not stupid.
And so I said to myself,
stop stuttering now.
Stop Stuttering now.
I said that dozens hundreds of times over and over and over.
And fortunately the storms went past and held onto the tree and soaking wet.
I came out of the tree and walked back to where I was living and then the next
day I got up,
I didn't see anybody and I was walking on,
on,
on this path and a sidewalk and there's a lady that I really liked a lot and uh,
but she was always attracted to the super self assured jocks and things like
that.
She was actually very kind and sweet,
but I didn't want to stare at her in the eyes because I would stutter.
And it's humiliating for us.
So the more humiliating us stutterers feel,
the more we stutter.
And so it's a really slippery slope.
And so I would avoid eye contact.
And so for the first time she walked towards him,
he says,
good morning,
Paul,
how are you?
She was always so nice to me and I was terrified because I'd embarrass myself.
And I looked at her straight in the eyes.
I said,
I'm doing fine.
How are you?
And I stopped stuttering in one day.
Whoa.
And this speaks to now what was been medically proven is that we can reset the
neurology of the human brain through neurogenesis.
I believe that experience allowed me to map new neurological pathways that
allows me to elocute in a way that I could not elocute before.
Used to hang out a lot with Dennis.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
hadn't seen him for years,
was at a restaurant in Chicago not too long ago.
And,
um,
and somebody said,
oh,
you guys are friends with Dennis,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
he's upstairs.
Oh really?
We go upstairs,
Dennis crying.
Oh my God.
I miss you guys.
Me and my buddy were hanging out with them.
Talent,
old stories,
you know,
seven or eight years,
haven't seen him.
This is great.
Like,
uh,
when you see a buddy you really love and it's really affectionate and Dennis is
one of those people.
At some point he just gets up and he wanders away.
I think he's going to take a piss.
Okay.
But 10 minutes goes by,
I say to the waitress.
To Dennis leave.
Yeah,
he left.
Okay.
I just figured he's gone.
It's just the way he is.
Right.
He wouldn't even say goodbye.
Just gone.
I get up the next morning I turned the television,
Dennis Rodman's in North Korea.
Okay.
I,
by the way,
I spent an hour and a half with them.
He didn't say anything.
We go about going to North Korea.
As I turned the television,
it's like very controversial.
Dennis Rodman to North Korea.
So I text my buddy and I say,
have you seen the news?
No.
What?
I say turn on the television.
And he said,
what channel?
I said,
it doesn't matter.
And two minutes goes by.
Holy Fuck.
Cause he went through the same thing,
you know,
and the radio program director came into my town knew,
and you know if you've ever been in radio,
when they come into town,
knew the first thing they're going to do is change everything cause they got to
put their own stamp on it or why are they there?
So this guy comes in and he goes,
well we're going to rebrand you.
He goes,
I want everyone to think of your name and instantly think of the brand and I'm
already,
you know,
brand.
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's what he said.
So I hate to say this because this will become a meme online that I will have to
live with the rest of it.
But it's an absolutely true story.
So the guy says to me,
he goes,
listen all a imagine a billboard that says Dan Carlin,
he fucks chickens.
And I said,
excuse me?
He goes,
yeah,
I mean,
so that anytime anybody thought,
if you,
they would think,
okay,
he's the chicken fucker and I'm going,
wait,
really?
He really said yes and I say,
I said to him,
I said,
I said two things,
dude.
I said,
the first thing is I got to live in this town,
right,
so really you want that to be the first thing people think.
Okay.
The second thing is I got to have a career after this stupid idea of yours fails
and you're like,
no,
you don't understand.
We're,
we're building up a mental image.
You'll be a household name.
I said,
yes,
I'll be the household name.
The guy who fucks chickens
and finding no,
he was,
after that,
I finally said,
I said,
dude,
do you want to step outside right now?
I don't mean my wife laughed at me because I'm already an old man.
When I'm saying,
she goes,
that would have been great.
I said,
no,
this is,
this guy was as old as I was,
but I mean I was so incensed and so angry that this guy would would be so
cavalier.
Your future human being and everything.
What is it about that look right,
that like cover,
you know,
pinup girl.
That's what it's called.
1950s pinup girl type of look.
What is it about that that's appealing?
Maybe it makes fat chicks look good.
How dare you Doug?
Stan hope.
Do you not realize it was a different day and age?
Like I didn't smoke blunts till I hung out with Charlie Murphy.
He was one of the hardest deaths that I ever had to deal with.
Really?
Yeah,
cause I wish I contacted him more.
I wish we got together more.
We were always on the road and and offstage.
Maybe one of the funniest guys of all time.
He took me to dinner and like he,
he was telling stories.
He,
he was,
he told the story that I texted you to ask him when you had them on.
I'm supposed to ask you about Johnny Gill who thought he could beat Oscar de la
Hoya.
Oh yeah,
man.
You know.
Wow.
How did you know where that one man,
I think it was Tom [inaudible].
He said that Johnny Gill,
Johnny Gill,
we're looking at the screen and his ass Hoya,
he's like,
you think Oscar de la Hoya could fuck you up?
I was like,
yeah.
He's like,
I know.
Right?
And I was like,
yeah man,
he's a professional,
but he would ruin your life.
And he was like,
Johnny Gill thinks he can fuck him up.
I was like,
what?
That's back when ask him was still,
you know,
finding too.
That's what made me really angry.
I asked him was whipping somebodies ass.
You know,
I'm sitting next to a balladeer,
you know,
I respect you.
You're singing on them.
Don't point to know frankly and go,
I could whip him that.
I don't want to hit that man.
He really said that vehemently man jumped up and I even,
I even,
I'm the fact that you brought it up,
it ain't like I'm snitching.
I told him Pharisees asking him the same room,
making sure that ask it knows that you feel that way.
I want to be there.
I'm making sure he knows that you uh,
balladeer crooner you could whip him.
Yeah,
man,
that was a,
to me that was the highest incidence incidence of the highest level man.
You make your money would Rose's flat in there and all that saying you're going
to look at a Friday and talking about how could whip him.
Come on,
man.
He needs to know that.
He needs to know you feel that way.
How's it fucking Mike Tyson?
Tiger story.
Yeah.
Oh,
that was a good story.
It's an incredible,
yes.
A man who,
one time I went to his house and it was fat,
six limos and nobody would get out.
The Limo s how come to mind is getting out the car?
They said,
hey,
you don't see that line standing over there.
Mike tastes the lane,
his front yard.
He's like,
hang over.
Starts the only man.
His house I went over there was a line in the front yard loose.
Wow.
He was on the steps like this with a heavy weight belt
on the line with the gap.
The Cup play.
Mike Katz,
who was like,
oh no man,
no.
Instead of cat,
it's a lion.
Charlie Murphy was at dinner with Maury Smith,
who's a former UFC heavyweight champion of the world.
I haven't salivary and we're all out at a restaurant and Charlie is convincing
everybody that the rich hand that y'all are sleeping on the ridge hand,
he's explaining some particular like martial arts move and they were,
they were laughing.
They would try and say Yay.
And Charlie was like,
no,
fuck you.
He goes,
you tell me.
I don't,
I don't hit you in the head with a rich hand,
but Charlie fucking gun who use the and was the me.
I see in the one of the very first UFC joints,
my med check with down,
knocked out a Yarbrough originating chocolate gum.
Never fought Yarbrough.
He fought some big jams.
Keith Hackney fought.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he did though.
That's Charlie talking about
look how wide his eyes are.
Look at the smile underneath his left arm.
Look at that guy laugh.
We're all going to go.
This is the point like Ralphy like Charlie,
like everybody.
We're all going to go that if you could go faster than the speed of light,
right to the time.
And then with a powerful enough,
uh,
telescope pointed at us to catch the light reflected.
Okay.
You could use,
just as satellite technology looks down on the earth,
you could see the reflection of the earth from that time and visually prove
everything you want it to.
Whoa.
What the light is coming from the earth as you go.
You would theoretically be looking at earth at that point,
right?
The reflection of the light.
It's a as it's a million miles away.
Yeah.
It,
no,
no.
If you light the light,
the light,
good time to be alive.
But as the human race,
as a person,
all of us,
there's no one gets out alive.
No.
One quicker.
We remember that.
The better.
We're all be
not work.
I was cut off a couple times.
Okay.